sveglia alle sei meno di tre ore di
sonno e più di due settimane di
preparazione e non so neanche perché sto
parlando con questa voce ma funziona
oggi sto per fare una cosa che sogno di
fare la tempo insieme una persona
speciale con la quale ho condiviso un
sacco di esperienze
abbiamo visitato l'asia passato giornate
a giocare col make up abbiamo lavorato
per l'europa e ho pianto personalmente
come disperato quando le cose non
andavano benissimo sto parlando di una
ragazza anzi di un'amica speciale che mi
farà da cicerone per la fiera di lucca
il lucca comics and games questo video o
un core del vero non sarebbe mai stato
possibile senza l'aiuto degli amici i
tre in line che è l'app che mi sta
permettendo di fare questa esperienza e
della quale vi parlerò a brevissimo
giusto il tempo di prendere il treno
senza troppi fronzoli una così
personalmente
personalmente un hub
personalmente senza troppi fronzoli un
apposito è svolta la vita io abito tra
roma e milano per lavoro mi muovo
veramente ovunque in giro per l'italia e
non sempre trovare il biglietto perfetto
è una cosa facile dicevo che grazie a
questa app un sacco di noi e se ne vanno
la prima cosa che ti permetterà di
comprare in maniera veloce e intuitiva i
biglietti d aparte treni diversi ma
anche di pullman al fine di trovare a
parte quello che ti di torna più tirate
ma allo stesso tempo quello più
economico e infine informazioni sul
treno che io di solito devo cercare in
stazione un pochino chiedendo in giro
guardando tabelloni qua invece binari di
partenza ritardi le carrozze più
silenziose le fermate tele trovi tutte
quante all'interno del telefono che
secondo me è la svolta
adesso sicuramente un apcom e tre in
line che aiuta un sacco a vivere più
sereno ma non ti può aiutare a
sopportare una volta può essere un
viaggio che estremamente noioso ed è qui
che entra in gioco io
ecco i consigli di guglielmo per
sopportare un viaggio estremamente
noioso contare gli alberi
e ora provate a farlo anche voi 12345
non è divertentissimo parlare con un
amico immaginario
ovviamente non ti darà risposte ma
provateci anche voi fissate il muro
accanto a voi e incominciate a parlare
calcolate che i vostri amici
il più delle volte hanno lo stesso grado
di interesse per quello che dite
osservare quello che fa il vicino si sa
la vita di ognuno di noi non sempre
piena di avvenimenti come vorremmo che
fosse
ma quella del tuo vicino potrebbe
esserlo utilizzate la tecnica
dell'occhio picchio di falco andata e
leggermente indietro col gusto spostate
la testa verso l'orecchio del vostro
vicino e con un occhio a picchio di
falco iniziate a spiare tutto quello che
fa rimorchiate il vostro vicino se la
dea bendata è stata magnanima potrebbe
essere capitata a quella volta sul
migliore in cui state vicino a un buono
o una buona perché guardare fuori dal
finestrino
quando potete benissimo perdervi nei
suoi occhi
provate a leggere un libro non importa
se avete la prima diventare se siete
degli analfabeti importante che sappiate
che all'interno di una pagina numeri
stanno in basso se stanno in alto sta
dipingendo di leggerlo al contrario pò
libro passeggiare per il treno a un
certo punto del viaggio alzatevi dal
vostro posto e fingete di andare in
bagno
a quel punto iniziate a passare da
carrozza 1 a carrozza ultima facendo
avanti e indietro avanti e indietro con
un lottatore olimpionico che fai 1200
stile fate una maratona con le dita
usate l'indice medio per correre lungo
il paesaggio che avrete di fianco è una
cosa che faceva anche in macchina
assolutamente inutile vi farà venire un
crampo alla spalla ma aiuterà sicura
mente a rendere il viaggio più veloce il
lucca comics and games lego testuali
parole del sito è uno degli appuntamenti
più emozionanti in ambito europeo
riguardo fumetti animazioni e giochi di
ruolo da tavolo videogiochi e fantasy
per arrivare alla mia destinazione ho
dovuto prendere un treno da roma a
firenze poi fare un cambio con un
regionale pino stracolmo di gente
direzione lucca
ora nonostante ci abbia scherzato su il
mio rapporto coi viaggi non è
assolutamente così negativo anzi che sia
per lavoro per amore per hobby per
curiosità o per avventura a volte
allontanasse al proprio nido è un modo
perfetto non solo per scoprire il mondo
che ci circonda ma anche per scoprire un
pochino di più noi stessi culture
differenti cibo straniero è forestiero o
addirittura esperienze che vivremo
solamente una volta nella nostra vita
stanno tutte da fuori e aspettano
soltanto che il coraggio di fare i
bagagli e aprire le ali
magari con un grande amico a farti
compagnia come nel mio caso con lei
alice come funziona e non ci sono mai
stato allora ci sono un sacco di
padiglioni in giro per la città adesso
andiamo di qua
tu sei tutto l'unica cosa perché dico
che non possiamo andare così
non passando a rischio devo vestirci
amanda che ci vestiamo invece ho pensato
io ho pensato alla mia maschera e alla
tua maschera
no anche se è una cosa molto quando l'ho
pensato ma ricordato molto tipo e al
mare di mettere mai in imbarazzo
sì
diverso allora di mari e qua dentro
mi piace no no no questo no questo non è
tutto questo non cederemo del suo questo
serve per dare un effetto robotic ok 6.3
sabato sera
no perché poi c'è comunque vedi questo
spesso di vista mutanda a messa sopra
sopra marsupio sì sì ci sta devo dire
che azzeccato la taglia che ringrazia e
orami silhouette mise in risalto da
questo è capito cioè è fatto apposta di
gore non lo so che sfiderà non mistica
sulle braccia e cioè quella v
ma non è il contrario adc che davanti
allo scopo che se da sposa con lo score
di direbbero notava costeranno disco the
matrix tua madre miemo verrà mentre mi
stile quanto in maniera massiva tuo
padre michele
ok ma mi sembra tanto cari a te perché
sei deliziosa io non sono contenta di
questa una maschera quanti hanno visto
nelle date e la sente di fare un giro
filtu calcola che nessuno ti riconoscerà
vanno male anche se togli la maschera no
se perdo mai sono pronti ed esami
considera che c'è chi è messo peggio di
te parlando di qualcuno in particolare
bene
no
il mondo
la classe cioè non capiamo perché ci
chiedono le foto siamo vestiti bene o
hanno veramente cattivo gusto
no niente
[Musica]
guarda
[Applauso]
e tv mm venerdì sera e sabato mattina
[Musica]
no molto perché non restino non sono i
punti per l'aria
è vero
sguardi di approvazione io penso di aver
fatto una banda di interpretazione
un albero
un fenomeno
bene bambino l'unica persona che
potrebbe mai prendere con sede a verso
damiano la maschera ma niente liner
vieni stress test incredibile di provole
spider man di nusco il secondo avviso da
onore
vogliamo davvero
vergogna
dico solo che gli anni e siamo insieme
grazie a guglielmo la prima volta che ho
scritto agnese sapendo che era fan ho
scritto io mi sono fatto mandare da lui
il video di saluto le ho scritto da
livorno
lei ha detto ti devo una birra possiamo
andare a prendere a birra e poi bene sia
innamorata sia chi ovviamente
[Musica]
ho visto una ventina ragazzi la mia
prima esperienza a lucca comics finisce
qui grazie a dice per avermi fatto da
cicerone grazie 3 line preferite mi6
fare questa esperienza meravigliosa
fondamentalmente dice tu sei stata utile
relativamente grazie non si nota
differenza
[Musica]